- Breaking that rule a little bit.
- Never in my life have I been
invited to somebody's Christmas.
- Well that to me says your a bad friend.
- Never in my life.
- And they don't want you at their party.
- [Voiceover] You are living
in some sort of fantasy.
- Ah...Christmas. The presents,
the family, the feasts.
The hustle and bustle, what
a trip. But is it wort it?
Because I recently heard
tell of Jewish Christmas
and I've got to be honest,
they may be onto something.
Christmas vs. Jewish
Christmas, it's debatable.
(regal music)
- I'm a Jew but I'm pro Christmas.
- I'm arguing for Jewish Christmas.
- Christmas Christmas will always win.
- There's a fair
comparison, but I'd go for
Jewish Christmas if I had to pick.
- Good old fashion regular Christmas.
- I'm team Jewish Christmas
and my opponent is a traitor
to her own kind.
(triumphant music)
- It's a day of movie
marathons. You know what movies
come out at Christmas? The best movies.
While Christians are busy
hanging out with their families
forced to hand out and do
family shit, I'm gonna be seeing
"Star Wars" for the third time.
- Have you ever gone to a
Chinese restaurant on Christmas
as a Jewish person? Hours
of wait. Really angry Jews.
It's every single person
with nowhere to go taking up
so much space, so much time.
- Sounds like you're at the
wrong Chinese restaurant
with the wrong Jews.
- Christmas is one of those holidays
that you always have to go
see your distant relatives.
Every year it's something
different, How's college going?
Oh, you're graduating. What's your plan.
- I'm excited to eat all
this Chinese food right here.
Chow Mein, Orange Chicken.
- Nothing says like, this festive,
like food you would
order to your dorm room.
- I got to Malibu in 20 minutes.
I went with a few friends,
guess who was on the beach.
Nobody, except for us.
- There is no traffic in L.A. on Christmas
- It's amazing.
You can drive wherever you
want Just for the fuck of it.
- The majority of Jews are not in L.A.
Their all, I'm a good old suburban Jew.
- Their all over the place.
- I'm a good old suburban Jew.
- The open road's everywhere.
- And there's fucking nothing to do there.
- Chinese foods a lot
better than Christmas food.
Like I would take Lo Mein over
this stupid ass snowman any
day. - You think this looks
worse than a fortune cookie.
Are you crazy?
- Eating dinner at 3pm just because
it's a holiday is absolutely absurd.
By 5 o'clock, when I
should be having dinner,
I'm already hungry again.
- That's because she CrossFits.
- It's just absolutely redic...
No, that's not because I CrossFit.
(shouting) - That's because she CrossFits.
Cause she CrossFits. Shhh. -
[girl with glasses}] It's because
people shouldn't eat dinner
at 3pm in the afternoon, Taylor.
- The actual reality of
Jewish Christmas is you
have to all agree on a
movie with your family.
With your family's friends.
- False, false.
- Yes, all have to go to the
I saw Benjamin Button in the
theater, Benjamin Button I saw.
(triumphant music)
Look what we have here.
We have some box...these are empty.
There's not even anything in here.
Which I think, you know,
represents Jewish Christmas
is that it's empty of emotion.
- I've done Jewish Christmas and
I've done Christmas Christmas.
Once you go Christmas you never go back.
- Christmas day comes, boom, you wake up.
You're stoked. You're in your PJs.
Your family's all gathered
in the living room
and it's, it's beautiful.
- Look at these cute ass snowmen.
Look, at these, beautiful, gorgeous.
(man laughing)
- Like, what time of year
is it totally excusable,
other than Christmas, to just
eat all this and it's okay.
And you can gain weight cause you're
layering your clothes. - Thanksgiving.
- We're having so much fun
cause we love Christmas.
- They look Jewish.
- Do you want white rice
or do you want cookies?
Do you want to make a gingerbread house?
Do you want everything
to smell like cinnamon
and open presents?
- I'm happy that I can
participate in Christmas
because of my like, duel
citizenship in the religion world
you know. You know like...
- Yeah, but that's, yeah, but that's it.
You get to be selective about the parts
of Christmas you celebrate.
- I'm just saying.
- You don't have to do
the whole shebang, you know what I mean?
- You know, I use to wake up and think
maybe Santa made a mistake
and maybe he gave me presents
this year and you know what, he never did.
- [Voiceover] He never did.
- He never, Santa doesn't make mistakes.
- That's right you're Jewish,
you've never experieneced
Christmas Christmas. And in fact this...
- Yeah, that's why I want it so badly.
- I hated Christmas before my
parents got divorced, okay.
(both laughing)
- This got so real.
- When it's Christmas Christmas
there's this mentality of
this day has to be great.
- No there's not. (laughing) - [Voiceover]
So everything's just, things get higher.
- I've been to people's houses like after
their whole Christmas thing and their like
this is what I got, I
got this, I got this.
There's wrapping paper
everywhere, the fire is blazing,
there's just a sense of warmth.
Movie theaters are cold.
Movie theaters are cold and
their playing Benjamin Button.
(jubilant music)
- Christmas, don't knock
it till you've tried it.
From a girl with the last name Levine.
- The actual spirit of Christmas
has been completely lost
and I stand firm in my belief that
it is better to be Jewish on Christmas.
- Shut up, Christmas is the best.
Coming from a Jew, it's the best.
- I'm just here to promote
today the idea that
Jew have it pretty good too, also
that I hate Santa. - Mozel tov.
(triumphant music)
- I'm so mad I'm gonna flip this
tray of cookies. (man laughing)
- Hey, hey. (shouting)
(triumphant music concludes)